1167 and the tribes of the steppe
roughly here are fighting conflict here
was limited in scale and waged between
small groups of nomadic warriors who
were fighting for the regions limited
resources
there were many tribes but the most
important ones were the tatar as the
carry id's and of course the mongols
these tribes had no formal written
languages or complex hierarchy simply
because they didn't need them they were
run by chieftains whose position was
inherited and it was their role to keep
the peace and lead the warriors into
battle the tribes of the steppe had many
different religions ranging from
Christianity to Buddhism but the Mongols
were ten Griest s-- Tengri ism was very
much linked with a nomadic nature of
mongol life for example there were no
fixed religious buildings like in China
or Europe in which Mongols would worship
the supreme God Tengri who was the god
of the sky the mongol religious leaders
were shamans called beki he would
communicate with the dead on behalf of
the living and also cure ailments or at
least they would attempt to because
medicine back then was frankly pants so
the late 12th century was a period of
great change for the people of the
steppe for a start the climate was much
milder meaning that there was more food
for their livestock and thus for them
you'd think the more food would mean
that there'd be less raiding but fun
fact no it's actually meant that herding
duties could be left to the women and
the small men could be spared for other
things like war the winner of these
internal mattock fights would absorb the
losing tribe which made governing more
complicated but importantly so the power
of individual chieftains grow
considerably up until the turn of the
thirteenth century of course no chief
would grow as great as the certain
chingus better known in the West as
Genghis although his birth name was
Temujin Temujin was the son of a Mongol
noble who was poisoned by the Tatars and
whose followers promptly abandoned him
over many years he built up a reputation
as a skilled leader and built many
enduring friendships after later
rescuing his kidnap wife Genghis and the
Mongols teamed up with the carriers to
destroy the Tatar laughter his victory
Temujin and then took the title Kahn
meaning ruler so now the Mongols and the
carriers were the dominant powers in the
region and as a result they immediately
became enemies and so those other guys
had to die
Temujin and his Mongols were victorious
and destroyed the carriers before
mopping up and assimilating the other
nomadic groups in the area this was all
done by 1206 when the leaders of the now
quite large Mongols met at what is
called a Kuralt I hear Temujin was
elected as the CAG on meaning the Great
Khan or the khan of khans he also took
the title Chinggis Khaan meaning fierce
ruler and so began the mongol empire
Seidner we're going to call him genghis
instead of chingus in this episode
because most people in the way
know him as that so now that Genghis and
the Mongols were dominant in the region
there were two options settlin lived the
rest of their lives in peace or conquer
literally everything shockingly Genghis
opted for the latter and turned his gaze
south to China he used to be entirely
ruled by the Song Dynasty but at this
point it was split into three states the
song still ruled in the south the North
was ruled by the Jin and in the north
west lay the kingdom of Western Jia whom
Genghis chose as his first target by
1209 Western Jia had submitted to
Genghis after he flooded the fields
around its capital and ruined its crops
it was now time to take on the Qin who
were a much more powerful foe and they
even had some large walls to keep them
uncle's out they were disconnected
though and the mongols could simply go
around them but that was the point it
was supposed to slow invaders down and
give the Chinese time to mobilize
Genghis invaded the Jin in twelve eleven
and by twelve fourteen art for a long
siege of the Jin capital Zhang do
nowadays called Beijing the Qin Emperor
submitted he then promptly moved his
capital south to kaifeng which Genghis
saw as a challenge and so back to war it
was genghis captured and then sacked
zhang do with the help of some jin
deserters who taught among us how to
siege a city before conquering this
territory by 1216
the mongols were unable to destroy the
jin however and so Ganga's left a force
there and turned his attention to other
lands genghis conquered many of the
nomads to the east and then looked to
this land called quar ism to which he
sent a trade delegation in 1218 which
the karez me a leader promptly put to
death this was not a clever thing to do
genghis now a bit angry decided that a
lot of people had to die for this by
1227 the karez mere lands were decimated
and the chunk of it was absorbed into
the mongol empire not all of it though
since genghis didn't want to overstretch
his forces this is just one
demonstration of how genghis was a
pragmatist another one being that he
promoted generals based upon their
talents not their birth with Suba died
the son of a blacksmith being the best
example genghis would die in 1227 was
succeeded as coggan by his son Agha died
he didn't simply become Kagome like a
monarch didn't had to be selected by the
nobles of the Empire in another choral
tie-in 1229 the only people who were
eligible to be made Kagome with the
descendants of Genghis Hamas dogged I
was selected without much issue the
seeds were sown for future division or
GERD I sought the construction of a
permanent capital of the mongol empire
which was completed in 1235 called
Karakoram so oh god I much like his
father expanded the borders of the
Empire in 1234 he with the help of the
Song Dynasty oversaw the final
destruction of the Jin before subduing
Korea sort of a
kept resisting forever oh god I then
sent his nephew Batou under the command
of subbu died to conquer lands in Europe
they did pretty well at this conquering
all of this land by 1241 and raiding
Hungary in Poland
the road to Central and Western Europe
lay wide open but the Mongols didn't
advance any further one of the reasons
may have been the death of Agha died in
1241 meaning that the Mongol Nobles in
Europe needed to return to Mongolia to
attend a Kurata in select a new leader
Agha died had no clear successor lined
up and after a five-year Regency he was
succeeded by his son Goya whose two year
reign did see gains in Anatolia this
time the succession was contested and it
was Mongkok oyx cousin who won out in in
1251 he was made Great Khan monka
cracked down on those who had opposed
him and then tasked his brother Hulagu
with conquering the realms to the
southwest
he did this with great enthusiasm and in
1258 baghdad the center of the islamic
world was taken and looted montgo also
conquered these territories in china
surrounding the Song Dynasty and also
invaded davia but they failed by 1259
the mongol empire looked like this and
it was in the same year the monka died
during a campaign against the song
monka hadn't named an heir and so two of
his brothers emerged as rival claimants
the first was Kublai who was proclaimed
Kurgan in kaifeng with only the nobles
who supported him being there the other
was a reek Bacco who was named Great
Khan and Karakoram naturally this meant
civil war and the Empire was divided in
its allegiance Cooper I held the immense
resources and wealth of China as well as
having an ally in hella gu who
controlled this territory known as the
Oh Kearney Arica Kerr had aid from this
land could the jagged I Carnot and also
from the European lands of the Empire
known as the Golden Horde by 1264 Cooper
I had won in arica Booker was imprisoned
and died but after this the Mongol
Empire would never truly be united again
the O Carnot in the Golden Horde were
almost permanently at war and even after
this their lesser cons of the Empire
only really paid lip service to Kublai
so being a Mongol in charge of what was
a predominantly Chinese Empire meant the
kübra had to adopt a combined means of
rule the Mongols were to outnumber to
simply fight everything plus they
weren't really wants for administration
Kublai this expanded the Chinese
bureaucracy although ethnic Chinese
subjects were barred from high-ranking
positions most high-ranking offices like
those in the army were filled by Mongols
whereas those in the bureaucracy were
filled by skilled foreigners who had
been moved from across the Empire Kublai
also sought to improve the Chinese
economy the first thing he did was
promised the Chinese that they wouldn't
be mistreated which to be fair to him he
did keep his word to supplement this
Hebrew
form the locos which despite the
reputation of the Mongoose as harsh
rulers were actually much more lenient
than the song down south true Bligh's
religious policies can largely be summed
up as yeah because he was at angriest
and had no interest in norm uncles
following his religion which was tied to
the land from which he came he allowed
Buddhists Muslims Nestorian Christians
and Taoist freedom of worship and places
at his core which for the time was
basically unheard of so Cooper I began
to take on the characteristics more akin
to the preceding Chinese emperors than
any of the great khans that came before
him he relocated the Capitol Twice first
from Karakoram to Shang do before
constructing a new capital haddad who or
can belief next to the ruins of the old
city of Zhang do he also made his claim
to legitimacy by creating a brand new
Chinese imperial dynasty the Yuan
Dynasty despite all of this crew blight
was still a mongol khan and so his mind
was interested in one thing sweet sweet
conquest he first demanded that the
japanese submit to him they said no and
so he invaded it went poorly also Korea
finally submitted which was nice of
course cuboids main target was obviously
the southern Song Dynasty since he
wanted to be the Emperor of all of China
progress here was much slower since the
song were formidable wealthy opponents
kübra was ultimately successful though
and by 1279 the Song Dynasty was no more
nuan dynasty was in control of the
entirety of China it was during the
height of Kublai's power that he was
visited by a man from the West a certain
Venetian called marco polo polo could
travel across the mongol empire due to
what is called the Pax mangalica the
Mongol peace the Mongol Empire was for
the most part extremely safe to travel
across and this facilitated massive
amounts of trade across what is known as
the Silk Road this same route would
later allow the bubonic plague to travel
from China to Europe but during the late
13th century was a positive the Silk
Road allowed for artisans merchants and
intellectuals to move across the world
and gave Kubla access to the greatest
minds of the age with which to run his
empire he made more attempts to invade
Japan in the 12 80s which all met with
typhoon related disaster he also tried
to finish off davia but once again the
mongols failed
Kublai also tried to conquer India as
his predecessors had but again like his
predecessors he failed
Cooper I have other struggles the most
notable being his capacity to exert
influence over the other Mongol Khan's
Chi do the leader of the chequered I
Carney was in open rebellion against
Kublai neo Carnot in the golden horde
were doing their own thing meaning the
Mongol Empire was well and truly
fractured at this point
Kublai would continue his rule until his
death
1294 after which the Mongol Empire would
only ever decline so what was the legacy
of the Mongol Empire
Genghis an his descendants had built the
largest contiguous empire in human
history and waged Wars of unimaginable
destruction many regions were ravaged
and de populated in the death toll of
the conquest was in the many millions
which in the 13th century was a sizable
percentage of the human population
the Mongols destroyed centers of
Commerce and learning but also built an
empire which in the end facilitated them
genghis is remembered as history's
greatest Conqueror and Kublai is
remembered for his religious tolerance
and competent rule the four Carnot's
would soon come to resemble those they
had conquered and would abandon the
Mongol traditions and religion the yuan
dynasty became fundamentally Chinese the
O carnate Persian and in the end they
left little traits that they had
descended from nomads who'd conquered a
world I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching and a special
thanks to James Bissonnette Thomas guest
Strich Adam Harvey in Winston Cawood if
you'd like to learn more about the
Mongol Empire there are some book
recommendations in the description below
you